welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka Vergara and in this
episode we will talk about two very
unique businesses and their website
hosting challenges
[Music]
my friend Christine is an amazing Baker
and started this bakery called cloudy
bakers where she sells her baked goods
in her newly rented store in California
after a few weeks in business she asked
for some help she wanted to build an
online presence for her business to
spread the word about her treats and
grow beyond California now it makes
sense to start a website with a fixed
menu to be displayed along with her
contact information and some other
details so that's what we did we needed
to create a static website with her
branding logo and beautiful picture of
her very tasty menu items in order to
accomplish this we started by purchasing
a domain called cloudy bakers calm on
Google domains now with this domain we
officially have an online business name
since all we needed was to establish an
online presence and make sure the people
know what cloudy bakers sells we decided
to use Google Cloud Storage to host the
static website we created a cloud
storage bucket called WWWE bakers calm
and uploaded all the HTML Javascript and
images like the menu and the logos in it
once done we made sure that all the
files in the bucket are publicly
accessible so the users can see the
website this was great but after about
six months Christine called me again her
business had grown and she was getting
more and more interest in her baked
goods and her customers were now looking
for options to purchase online but she
had to work with some constraints she
had very limited help from a developer
to update the site to take online orders
she was anticipating a higher volume of
cookie orders in December because
holidays and budget was also tight given
these challenges she had to pick an
option to host the site such that she
does not have to worry about
infrastructure needs if the products got
popular and try
it grew from few users to thousands of
users so I recommended that she used
managed compute platform cloud run since
cloud run is server less it abstract
Sallee all the infrastructure management
so she could focus on what matters most
selling more of her amazing cookies we
pointed this newly created website to
the domain name and cloudy bakers could
now take online orders this recipe
provided them a wide range of features
that made scalability load balancing
logging monitoring and security much
easier than if she had to build and
manage this website herself cloud run
also provided her business the
flexibility to code in any programming
language because the applications
deployed as a container and Google
seamlessly launches and scales the
application as needed
Christine's business is off to a great
start and she's very happy that she
chose cloud run to host the website so
she could focus all her attention on
baking if you would like to learn how to
build websites on cloud run we've got a
video for that check it out now let's
consider Express food Express food is an
online grocery shopping platform their
market leader and have been around for a
long time they currently host their
website on-premise and are looking to
move to cloud the CEO is convinced that
this move will lead to benefits in total
cost of ownership operational
expenditures and allow the teams to
focus on their core business Express
food has a complex website with varying
server configurations with specific
memory SSD and GPU requirements given
this specificity it was clear that they
needed more options and control than a
managed platform could offer so I
proposed a lift and shift approach using
compute engine this recipe was apt for
express food because the teams had
complete control of the system and
flexibility they also had familiarity
with the virtual machine configurations
from
on premise world and can continue to
apply the concepts in Google cloud
platform without having to learn new
concepts they migrated the web server
application server the database to
Google cloud by creating Google compute
engine instances and mapping the memory
and CPU of the currently used on-premise
instances Express food sees variable
traffic patterns depending on the
seasons and the times of the day so we
also applied auto scaling policies in
conjunction with load balancing by
setting up an auto scaler that scales
based on load on the instances the CEO
is happy that moving to cloud led to
reduce operational expenses as a result
of auto scaling and the engineering team
is happy that they don't have to
capacity plan for the purchase of new
hardware a win-win situation for the
Express food team but still there was a
challenge they were facing their feature
launch speed was really slow digging
further we found that they had large
development teams working on different
features but most of them were not able
to launch due to dependencies on each
other since the website was a huge
monolith the feature rollouts had to be
combined together which is not efficient
especially for the teams and features
that are small quick updates to solve
this issue
I recommend it that Express foods create
micro services so the teams can work on
individual services removing the rollout
dependencies on each other
breaking the monolith into different
services to componentize is best
achieved through containerization so the
next logical move for express food was
to containerize the services off the web
application this didn't just increase
the speed with which they were able to
innovate but also provided Portability
and manageability if you are looking to
use gke to deploy your web application
follow the link in the description below
all right so let's summarize what we
learned today
we saw how cloudy Baker's was able to
establish
their online presence by creating a
static website on Google cloud storage
and then utilized cloud run to expand
their online presence with minimum
resources and effort we also learned how
Express food used Google compute engine
to host their existing legacy on-premise
website on Google cloud in least amount
of effort possible and eventually
containerized the website following the
microservices architectural principles
leading to rapid deployment and
efficiency that's all for today on get
cooking in cloud here's hoping you can
whip up something great join us in the
next episode where we will cook a new
dish disaster recovery on Google cloud
if you would like to share your feedback
on this series write a comment below or
tweet us and if you would like to see
more such content then don't forget to
Like and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
[Applause]